well if you got your kids a Nintendo
switch for Christmas make sure to Chuck
it in the garbage as fast as Reacher
throwing a barbecue I'm sorry for
missing last week's recap I had to spend
time with my niece who insisted we watch
a 100 hours of Bluey but now we're back
with a pretty action-packed episode so
let's not waste any time get to the
point smells like monkey in here
and just a reminder I have not read the
books so there will be no book spoilers
in this video our episode begins with
the aftermath of the warehouse explosion
from the end of episode 5 the shooter
from Calvin Fran's funeral claimed that
it was none other than former special
investigations member Tony Swan that he
was hired by the last few episodes has
seen Reacher struggling whether or not
his former team member could turn like
this Reacher's been adamant that Swan is
a good guy and this might be partly
because Swan actually took a bullet for
Reacher in a drug bus gone bad once
again it's odonnell who's quick to
accuse Swan of being a turncoat but if
you've seen my episode 4 video you'll
know that I think odonnell and to a
lesser extent Dixon could actually be a
secret villain now I could totally be
wrong here but Russo says the explosion
was caused by an IED trip wire that only
a pro or someone in the military would
know how to assemble odonnell is said to
quote be in position at the time of this
explosion so is it not possible that he
was the one to set this up I mean he
does have that military experience Russo
talked about the next lead finds Reacher
and team investig ating Marlo Burns's
abandoned car you may remember that
Dixon and Neely searched through the new
age director of operations home in
episode 4 to see that she left in a
hurry while looking at the security
footage at a nearby convenience store
neie notes that Marlo's daughter Jane
has a Nintendo switch meaning that if
they can grab her gamertag they can
basically track where she is and Jane's
Nintendo was set up way back in episode
4 Jane's a gamer and bonus points if you
caught Reacher reaching for a Clark Bar
and nod to his obsession with them in
season 1 collect bars are the best our
murderous comic book nerd am continues
his Killing Spree when stopped by a
parking cop in order for her to fill out
her warning she needs his ID which will
undoubtedly flag him since he stole the
identity of the now deceased doctor from
episode 4 and while the team waits for
Jane to log into her switch so that they
can track Marlo's location reach your
plans for some shy but Dixon has dicks
on the mind that's the worst pun because
nothing says romance like having sex in
the house of the woman who tried to kill
you meanwhile Russo meets up with his
boss at the NYPD a man by the name of
Lieutenant Marsh the same guy who told
him to keep an eye on Reacher and his
team the real reason he wanted Russo to
keep an eye on Reacher was that he was
being paid off by Langston to do so
that's how Langston always seemed to be
one step ahead of Reacher in knowing
where he was now I will say that
Marsha's reasoning for taking Langston's
money in exchange for info is pretty
weak he basically St stes that Langston
isn't the type of guy you say no to he
was kind of forced into it and that
terrorists using missiles overseas isn't
America's problem it's also heavily
implied that Russo's father died from a
a dirty cop or B that he refused to
become a dirty cop himself that's why
Russo goes off the handle every time
Reacher accuses him of being dirty the
person he loved more than anything died
because he refused to be corrupt and
Corruption is a big theme of this
episode in a flashback operation kite
Runner an investigation to military
personnel smuggling heroin out of
Afghanistan is officially terminated all
because the military can't have the new
Colonel looking bad if others found out
tons of heroin was being smuggled by our
own soldiers under the Colonel's watch
it would not be a good look now Reacher
says he'll follow orders and do what
he's told but knowing Reacher I wonder
if this isn't the last time we've heard
of operation kit Runner the real
Bombshells this episode come from Marlo
Burns who Reacher and the team are
finally able to pinpoint at her friend
Chad's house Reacher wants to know why
Marlo would give them an address to an
ambush the same Ambush we saw in episode
3 but Marlo swears she had no idea that
it was actually Langston who gave her
this address in fact Marlo had been
working with Tony Swan to find out what
Langston was up to at new age in episode
5 we learned from Russo that all the
security Personnel at New Age except for
Tony swan were from the same NYPD
Precinct in under investigation by
Internal Affairs they all retired and
suddenly the charges went away with
Langston hiring his former buddies and
giving them cushy jobs at New Age this
is why Marlo hired Swan to keep an eye
on these guys and when Swan found out
something bigger was going on here he
enlisted Orosco and Sanchez to dig
deeper what swan found was that an
unusually high amount of microchips were
being disposed of after being flagged as
defective this was done on purpose by
one of Langston's dirty Engineers who
was secretly stalking 650 of these chips
so that they could eventually be placed
in these missiles Langston then gave
Marlo this bag of money which she left
behind at her home it was money Marlo
said to ensure she didn't look clean in
all this this is likely why she left it
behind it was blood money so now Reacher
and the Gang have another Target on
their list this engineer but they also
have a new strategy to get right to
Langston Langston doesn't know that
Reacher with Marlo and thus they use her
to arrange a meeting at a creepy truck
Depot but before they get there they
drop off Marlo's daughter with Russo
which turns out to be a terrible idea
since he's hunted down by a group of
armed men Russo himself states that he
isn't sure if these are Langston's men
or that dirty comp Lieutenant Marsh's
now Marlo is a complete idiot and freaks
out when Langston arrives basically
screwing up the entire Ambush and
putting everyone's life in jeopardy the
team do a pretty good job at escorting
Marlo to safety while Reacher stays
behind and rambos his way through
through Langston's goons until it's down
to just the two of them I also thought
it was a pretty cool strategy to call
Langston's phone to figure out where he
was langon however is Saved by the Bell
or in this case helicopter where he
makes his Escape but the most dramatic
moment of the episode is Russo's Last
Stand to save Jane he Valiant takes on
his attackers getting shot twice in the
process and just to show you how
Cutthroat these guys are they've been
instructed to kill the girl too it's not
always Fair kid
yes neie odonnell and Dixon come to the
rescue but a little too late Russo is
fading fast and the last shot of him he
looks ominously still he looks pretty
dead to me but with the sounds of
nearing ambulances who knows if he'll
make it to episode 7 but now I turn it
over to you what did you think of the
episode and what do you think will
happen next I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
he was stopped by barbecue he died from
trans
fats